[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Amber is
in Houston Texas hi Amber how are
you oh Uncle Dave I have a bit of a
heart uh heartbreak um I'm calling for
your advice regarding my father's uh
finances please okay what's going on um
he well we he has three different credit
cards in the total of
$26,000 m he's fallen for every scam
he's 81 years old he's fallen for he's
made every Nigerian prince Rich at this
point wow we're intervening in his
finances so his bills we can help with
his bills we can help he's got his
mortgage covered with Social Security uh
bills are 2300 approximately he brings
in
$2,091 the total credit card outstanding
amount is
26,000 and we don't know at this point
whether he should declare bankruptcy or
we should let those credit cards go into
default and try to negotiate with the
collectors I'm just not sure how to help
with those
things I'm I'm guessing he has no
money he has no money he brings in uh
1926 in Social Security what what's the
what's the house
worth a lot we're trying to keep it the
house
550 probably okay what's the o on
it
340 okay all right in Te is he in
Texas no Oregon
okay
ah okay well I I am not I happen to know
Texas law because it's unusual I don't
know Oregon's law but I suspect it's a
standard a fairly normal state which
would mean that they eventually could
take a lean against his house if they
sue him okay if you don't pay him and
they sue him they take a lean against
his house he has no money to pay them
there's no money in this
budget right and he has no money does he
have a car right uh not one that's worth
anything no he has a vehicle but my
brother gave it to him it's on its last
legs like $1,000 or something yes under
three yes okay all right uh um and you
have
siblings yes okay uh how are the
siblings as far as money do you have any
do they have any can can we get a can we
get a group together and chip in and
come up with 10 grand and settle $26,000
with a bad credit card
debt yes okay yeah let it go bad Let It
Go bad and then go settle it before they
take it before they take a lean on his
house so go bad don't pay the minimum he
don't he don't have money pay the
minimum with with the numbers you gave
me he can barely pay the house payment
and
eat right he's been working physically
as 81 trying to make the payments yeah
so he's been bringing in a little bit to
cover but we've been making up the
difference
yeah okay so let it go to collections
and then just fight it out with settle
it out sell it out for a quarter on the
dollar for cash destroy his credit so he
can't get anymore in the process
yes that's what that does is he living
alone he is right now we plan on moving
there in three years um but so we've
taken I've taken over his finances we've
cut credit cards he he had every spyware
on his computer so we're trying to get
rid of that well what's his mortgage
payment because my worry is his expenses
keep going up he makes the same amount
of money you guys are chipping in for
the next 10 20 years to try to support
his lifestyle which ain't much that's
what my husband says that he needs to
sell the house and make other payments
we're trying to this is his family home
and so we're it's nostalgic to us then
mortgage is 1756 to answer your question
goodness and so so he has 2,000 coming
in 1756 going to mortgage he doesn't
have the money to eat then does
he no and so we're putting in $1,000 to
cover his bills and well that Nostalgia
is going to get replaced with this core
memory and so I'd rather sell the house
and have him retire with dignity than
have your Nostalgia tied up in this
keeping him in this awful situation
you're paying the
Thousand yes my brother and I oh your
brother and I there just two of
you um there are three of us but only
two that are financially stable okay and
the um you have a written agreement
where you recoup that when he passes
before we start splitting the house
Equity up
no we thought about putting into the
trust and getting the name the home into
our name so he can't no I'm talking
about your other sibling shouldn't get a
third uh until you get your $1,000 a
month
back we haven't yet no we yeah I know
you're right yeah I am right and this is
going to come up later and it's G to get
it's going to get real testy later when
the one that doesn't have any money
thinks that she hit the lotto or he hit
the lotto when the house is up for sale
and papa died oh so please get this
dialed in the right thing to do
financially is sell the
house and help him make a transition
into another place that he pays cash for
and you pay off these debts and we put
him on a budget that's the right thing
to do mathematically what I'm describing
with an 82y old is very very
difficult yes
emotionally Family House Nostalgia all
the things we're talking about about
here so what probably will happen is you
all will limp along feeding this at
$1,000 a month and you'll chip in and
get
$10,000 together to knock out the
$26,000 in bad old credit card debt his
credit will be destroyed when he passes
you'll sell the house recoup the $10,000
plus the $1,000 a month that you put in
before you split with your sibling who's
not putting anything in and that's all
in writing now if you're willing to feed
it to that tune just to keep him in the
house
house the only reason you're doing that
by the way there's only one reason
you're doing that that's to keep him in
the
house yes so the strain that you're
putting on your brother's finances and
your finances to do all of that is only
to keep your dad in this house which if
you've got $2 million it's no big deal
if you got 20,000 bucks and you're
throwing a thousand of it that's that's
a
lot we have a million and 401k yeah so
we plan but but our daily you know my
budget is dialed in yeah we have 50 we
follow your plan so we have 15 going
into we just make sure you you've got to
go do your paperwork now and if Dad will
not give you to sign over full power of
attorney and um all decision-making
rights to you and your brother and your
sister will not understand or your
brother whatever the third one is agreed
to you recoup before you split uh in
writing then any of those end this
discussion and we sell the
house I understand okay make it Crystal
Clear yeah everyone needs to have every
T crossed every eye dotted and everyone
is on the same page and discussing this
because your dad's of his right mind
he's just susceptible to
scams yes he's not he's not like in
third stage dementia or something right
not yet no okay all right so and you
know he's 82 so statistically you're
going to do this for two years or so I
don't know what his health is like but
he could do it for 10 George is Right
could do it for 20 George is right those
are possibilities but statistically you
know we're not doing this for a long
long time and the other thing you I
would be real clear on is this is what
we're going to do for now we reserve the
right to decide to sell the house
later like you you may reach the end of
your rope on this your husband might
your brother might well and that from a
husband's standpoint if it were your
wife and are in-laws and you see
financially this is a poor decision that
would really be I don't think it's a
poor decision because you're going to
get your money back out of the equity
and basically you're C you're putting a
strain on your cash flow but you're not
it's not costing you anything at the end
of the story and the strain on the cash
flow is in return for your dad getting
to live out his last days in in his
family home that's the trade you're
making and I don't necessarily think
that's a bad trade as long as
everybody's on board and everybody's
signing up for this but Dad you do one
more stupid scam we're
done uh sister brother you don't agree
to a recoup we're done you're not going
to live on a budget and we're going to
pay your house payment you're going to
and I'm going to manage your money
you're going to sign over a power of
attorney we're done we're done there are
there are stipulations to playing this
through and putting the strain on our
family